Everybody!
Hey guys!
Oh my gosh!
Okay.
I...
Whoa!
Batman!
Today's the day!
We will be finishing Batman!
Finally!
Also guys, I don't know if you guys noticed this, but do I look a little different to you all?
So for those who don't know, I have a... I was raised by a single parent.
I.e.
I only have one... Okay, not for real single...
I meant like...
This skin suit... Okay, I have a mom and a dad.
But for this skin suit, I only have one mama.
I don't have a...
I don't have a papa.
Because my mama is my papa.
So...
I was...
This skin suit...
My mama is my papa.
So...
Yesterday...
Yesterday, my mama papa...
Did a little bit of some refurbishing for my skin suit.
Because my skin suit was very, very old.
So now...
Now, if you guys follow me on Twitter, you might have noticed I...
I posted a little picture on the Twitter.
Because, I can do this now.
I can do this now.
It's so good.
Do it again, Tokia!
Oh my god, do it again!
So yeah, I can also do this, but it's not as cool as the other thing.
It's not as cool though, it's not as cool to be fair.
This is the coolest part.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She's perfect.
But yes, the skin suit got a little bit of an upgrade.
We put in the washing machine too, cleaned it up a little bit, gave it a little bit... it's not as like, you know, it's not as old.
Well, it's still old, but like, it's not as bad as before.
You know like when you get like, when you go to like the Apple store and then you like buy a refurbished iPhone.
That's basically me.
That's me right now.
I'm just a refurbished used iPhone at the moment.
Don't worry.
Other news!
I got my play button today!
I got it today!
I still can't believe I named it Doki Bird FPS VTuber TTV Facebook YouTube.
I can't believe!
You can name... Did you guys know you can name your play button anything?
And I was like, there's no way.
There's no way they would let me name my play button Doki Bird FPS VTuber.
Because VTuber TTV YouTube Facebook.
Like you know like I saw it.
It was there.
It was actually there.
And I was like, holy shit.
There is a way.
A fucking course.
My only play button that I own.
And I had to name it the most fucking dumbass name I could put on there.
Also, another... There's so many updates.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many updates I have to give you guys.
But I was talking to like for those who aren't into like the Apex community stuff.
For those who don't know who Nicewig is.
Nicewig is like one of the main...
One of the casters for like...
Apex Legends.
He's like a really well known content creator in Apex.
And he actually did like casting for like the Japan's like Apex Festival.
Like in Japan like last week.
But...
Nicewig and Tempo.
Tempo who is like the manager for TSM.
He's like the manager for TSM.
And also organizes all the Apex Legends scrims.
In the pro community.
Anyway.
Tempo and...
Wig convinced me to sign up for the Challenger Circuit for ALGS.
So...
The besties are gonna be competing in ALGS Challenger Circuit.
I think like next week.
I don't know which one we're joining.
But they were like, Doki are you down for it?
And I was like, you know what?
Fuck it.
I don't... like we might get knocked out in the first round.
But...
Fuck it.
Let's do it.
So I'm gonna be doing...
I'm gonna be doing the Challenger Circuit with Nicewig and Tempo.
Like Tempo was like...
Doki no.
We can make it to the semi-finals.
I was like...
Okay.
I was just like... Tempo.
We're gonna be IGL'd by Wig.
None of us scrim.
Scrims is not considered scrimming.
I have been busy trying to speedrun.
Restarting my career right now.
I don't know what you mean.
If you think that we're gonna make it.
To the semi-finals.
I don't know what you're talking about.
It'll be fun.
It's gonna be fun.
But I do not think we're gonna make it all the way to the semi-finals.
Um...
Anyway.
I think it's either next week or the week after that.
We're just gonna see what Wig's schedule is gonna be like.
Because it's all dependent on him.
Since he's the busy one out of the three of us.
Um...
I was also invited to the Apex Invitationals.
For those who don't know.
There is a...
They just recently announced the Nessie Cup Invitationals.
In NA.
And they are going to be the most popular.
And I was invited to participate.
In at least one of them.
Because...
Well to be fair.
It's more so I was like, Tempo can I join?
And he's like, yeah.
So like...
That was basically how it went.
Because I was like, oh hey.
I just saw this.
Can I join?
Yeah you can.
I was like, sweet.
So...
So I'm going to be there too.
Um...
For the...
Hey and it's...
I don't even know if I'm going to win any money.
But it was like $25,000 or something.
I don't know.
It was like, wait let me see where I could find the...
Um...
Let me see if I could find like the details of it.
It was like something...
I just saw it pop up on my Twitter.
And I was like, can I join?
Yeah you can.
Cool.
Yeah.
Alright.
Apex Legends.
Nessie Cup.
Oh yeah, yeah.
It's 25... what is it?
Holy shit.
Okay.
Each event...
Wait!
It's 50,000!
Holy fuck!
Okay.
Apparently each event is $50,000 prize pool.
Yeah!
It's like mini games too.
Which is the best part?
It's like... and there's like three of them.
So I asked if I could join like...
at least one of them.
So...
I wanted to do the mini games one.
Because like there's hide and seek and stuff like that.
And like fisting.
Like punching people out.
And I was like...
I'd rather do the ones where I can like not actually shoot my gun.
And that's fine with me.
Because there's like...
three different invitationals.
The second one is like where you actually have to shoot your gun and play as a team.
But the first invitational and the third invitational is like you get to fuck around and you can...
you don't have to like actually shoot your gun.
So I was like I would like to be in either of those for that sweet 50k.
Like not having to shoot my gun?
Sign me up.
So yeah.
So those are like the apex updates.
For uh...
For like...
When is the first one again?
That one is on March 7th.
So I might be on the March 7th one.
I'm not sure yet.
I'm just waiting for...
I'm just waiting for like to know which one I'm gonna be in.
But there's gonna be...
No it's a 50k prize pool.
Of course it's not per person.
What the fuck?
I feel like that if it was per person like I feel like that money would be used instead to improve Apex more.
I do not think that they would be willing to give 50k per person in a random tournament.
I'd rather have that money be used in Apex Legends in general and just improve the game.
Also!
LilPastaBoy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh boy.
I sure am excited for the Facebook streams.
I mean it says so in your play button.
No one lies on the internet.
Of course not.
Don't worry.
I never said when I'll be streaming on Facebook.
I never said when.
Guess you just gotta wait until it happens.
But yeah.
Lots of fun little updates for all of us.
I know I wrote down some stuff too.
I was like working the entire day.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
It was a lot of work today.
But yes!
Anyway let's actually finish Batman!
I swear.
Okay.
How many times do you guys think I said Batman?
I think I'm gonna crash guys.
What?
Guys.
Please I just wanna finish Batman.
That's all I want.
Let me finish Batman!
I love.
I love I can do this now.
Alright here we go.
What?
You don't even have a dec...
I'm gonna go to bed.
And then the doctor.
Slept fine ever since.
Joker what is up with you and like breaking people's legs Joker?
Like at this point I think it's like a fetish thing.
You're always breaking people's legs.
Broke it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki.
It's my birthday today and I'm glad I was able to catch your streams.
Been watching your VODs for around two years.
And first recently started to watch you live.
I always enjoy watching your streams.
Enjoy your content.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Broku.
Alright time to fist this plant.
Oh shit!
Get away.
How the fuck?
Get away!
Alright.
Goodbye.
There's no cameras.
No witnesses.
I have to go all the way there?
Can I?
Okay.
Alright that's fine.
I can get there.
Okay.
I gotta make sure.
Oh wait teeth!
Where's the teeth?
I hear teeth!
Oh teeth!
Nice.
Alright here we go.
I don't...
I think like...
What?
Door's locked.
Is there another way?
Okay thank god there's another way here.
I was gonna be like No please don't make me go the long way.
Please.
Is it supposed to be right outside?
What do you think you can do Batman?
I am everywhere.
My babies know your every move.
I'm gonna be so sad if she's not school.
Ow!
You and your car are arrogant enough to think you can destroy us.
You will fail.
And we...
We will become the most powerful force on the planet.
Who's we?
You think the Joker gives a fuck about you Ivy?
He's always a solo act.
He barely gives a fuck about Harley.
He's always like selling Harley off to the next guy.
You think you're gonna be different Ivy?
You're just delaying the inevitable.
I can fix her.
Oh she's talking about her and the plants.
Oh that makes more sense.
Yeah it's gonna be like who the fuck is we?
Gotta make sure I fist every plant around me.
The other sniper.
If I don't look at the other sniper he doesn't exist.
If you don't acknowledge the problem it'll eventually go away.
Right?
Oh shit.
What if they're into fisting?
What's going on about the plants of hers?
When I finish with Batman I'll be coming after you Joker.
Will you really?
Oh that's gratitude isn't it?
Fuck women.
You give them presents, experimental...
Whoa!
Joker!
Ow.
Who the fuck shot... who's shooting me?
Oh above.
Come find me when you're done with Batman.
Oh little bit faster.
No no no no no no no no no!
I'll take this.
Whoa
Joker!
Whoa ow!
Who the hell!
I salute my fallen enemy!
Oh my god.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
No!
Okay.
At least I get to fist these plants again.
You will pay Batman for hurting my babies.
Of course.
Does she have a going on about those plants of hers?
When I finish with Batman I'll be coming after you Joker.
There's no waiting.
Will you really?
I can't grapple.
There's too many people talking.
Presents, experimental chemicals, and nice costumes and they still turn on you.
I... I still hit him.
It's gonna be like I missed.
Ow!
Where?
No!
If I keep running you can't catch me!
I'll just keep dodging.
I have no stamina.
It's 2010!
Ow.
It's okay.
We can hack this.
Alright.
It's 2010.
There's no stamina in this game.
I can dodge forever.
How the fuck do I?
I need to remember how to hack.
I need to remember how to hack again.
Please.
Please!
Where's the green?
Oh, there it is.
I really don't want...
I'm too lazy to walk around.
I...
Ooh!
Interview tape.
No!
Don't make him trauma dumb!
You're gonna fall in love!
No!
Don't you remember what happened to Harley the moment he starts trauma dumping?
It's over!
It's so fucking over!
I wonder if there's anything at the...
Ooh, can I scan this?
No, I can't scan this thing.
I thought there'd be something here.
Wait, how do I get inside here?
You're gonna...
You're gonna be like, I can fix him!
And it'll be over!
It'll be over for you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So that's how it works.
Redpixel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi Doki, congrats on the play button.
I wonder if it's possible that the name take up the entire width of the plaque for the next one.
I don't know.
If I ever get a million, I'm just like thinking if I should like...
If I should add more to it or just do Doki Bird.
I was like, do I... I mean the best thing about it is that you can technically you can buy like unlimited play buttons.
It's like around like a hundred... I don't remember it was like a hundred... it was like...
I remember I asked about it before.
It was like two hundred dollars, I think.
You can buy like unlimited play buttons.
So it's not like they... they send you the first one for free and then they... and then the rest you can pay for extra copies.
So I'm just like... do I actually get a real one?
Or do I keep... do I keep adding more to it?
Let's see...
It's me.
I mean...
Good for you for the photosynthesis.
I mean we need more trees for oxygen.
So like good on you Ivy.
Good on you.
Oh hey.
I need that actually.
We were the ones to fix this city.
And the city would thank us.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So you're saying if we super chat you two hundred dollars, we can request a new play button for your collection?
Um...
In theory, yes.
In theory.
I can... if you... if you like, you know, super chat me.
Two hundred dollars.
In theory, I could order a play button.
If I wanted to.
I could technically just decorate an entire wall with just like silver play buttons that you've like sent me money to buy for.
In theory, yes.
Chat personalized play button.
Cause the thing is, the reason why they do this is cause like if your channel is owned by like multiple people, so you can like buy more play buttons for the rest of the people in your like YouTube team.
So in theory, I could be like you guys are part of my team and I just buy like an X amount of play buttons and just name it, just name it in with whatever suggestions you give me and just order like, I don't know, like twenty of them of different fucking names.
Yes, in theory, we could do this.
But the best thing about this is that this is all theoretical.
Stephen, towards the play button.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes,
this is all theoretical, guys.
It is possible.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, you know what to do, boys.
Play buttons, don't go.
Thank you for the super chat still.
Thank you.
And that's a play button theory.
Not gonna lie, I'm pretty sure the what was it called?
The game theory channel is gonna die the moment he like the moment he uh the moment he like leaves the channel for good.
Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa play button.
It's fun.
Iridescent, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
I'm all for the theoretical play.
Okay, how about this?
You guys want me to do?
Okay.
Alright, I'll let you guys name I'll buy, I'll purchase an extra play button and I'll let you, I like how I'm saying all this while like I'm slowly killing Ivy and she's like crying about nature and I'm like play button.
Let's talk about play buttons.
Anyway, um I'll let you guys name one play button.
Are you ready for me?
Do you think you can handle me?
I don't know if I wanna buy like 20 play buttons.
Whoa!
I'm waiting in here.
Come to me.
Whoa!
Trying to promise me a good time, Ivy?
Damn!
That's a shook thick.
Okay, let me fly over real fast.
Whoa!
Give me a sec.
Just gotta fist this one too.
It's just a theory.
Just a joke.
Haha!
Unless...
Thank you for the super chat.
Uh, Black Deer.
Thank you, thank you.
I vote for the name.
That's...
Thank you for the Thank you, thank you.
Alright, okay.
How about this?
We're gonna make a community post?
Oh, shit.
Are they like...
Did they get poison Ivy'd?
Whoa!
What about Harley?
That's okay.
We won't be killing anybody.
You can buy a punch and make a throne out of them.
LordPacky, thank you for the aca-aca soup.
Thank you.
Alright, I think it's like this way.
Right?
Yeah, it's this way.
Alright.
Alright, we will make a community post after this stream for all you guys to suggest the names and then I'll make a poll for you guys to...
One...
The Doki Bird FPS VTuber TTV YouTube Facebook is my play button.
And then I'll order another one for the Dragoons so you guys get a play button too.
And you guys get to decide.
You guys will fight for the name you want on that play button.
Cause technically Dragoons are part of the team.
Cause I couldn't have got 100k without you guys.
Wait, she's not swole!
What's the point?
What's the point if she's not swole?
Why doesn't the bane juice make her swole?
Holy fuck, what?
This looks...
This looks so wrong.
Okay I don't know...What do I do?
What the fuck do I do?
Oh God, what do I do?
Batarangs?
What do I do?
Okay.
Is it Bataran time?
Batarang.
Oh shit, it is Batarang!
Batarang!
Oh fuck.
Okay, it's Bataran.
Always the Bataran.
Okay, open your mouth, Ivy.
Batarang!
Wait, I can do two Batarangs.
Woo!
Alright.
Don't worry.
Batarang!
Ow.
Okay, only one Batarang apparently.
I can only do one Batarang at a time.
The voice acting!
What about the voice acting?
Can you please...
Please, give me the details of what you mean by that.
Yes, I can do that.
Yes, I'm calling you out.
Fuck, I didn't see your name.
But whoever said that, I'm calling you out right now.
What do you mean by that?
Very good voice acting.
It's just very good voice acting.
She was clearly doing so well.
Like, that's what I mean.
Exactly what he means.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nice.
What kind of boss fight is this?
Ivy, come on.
You got the bang juice.
You should be stronger than this.
Alright.
Nice.
We just gotta run.
Thank God for like...
You know what?
I'm gonna say it.
Fuck Souls genre for making Samana a thing.
Hahaha.
I'm gonna say it.
Not every game has to be Souls-like.
Sometimes I don't... I want to be able to run forever.
Okay.
Batarang.
Nice.
Alright.
And also realism.
Fuck the realism shit.
I'm trying to play a man that's wearing fucking underwear outside of his regular suit.
There's no realism to this.
Alright.
She's like one hit.
She's loud.
Okay.
Who wants me to tone this down?
Alright.
Let me...
I want fun, not reality exactly.
Alright.
It's fine.
I win.
Yay!
Hahaha.
I keep it.
Can I just... Hello?
Oh.
Explosives gel.
Okay.
Alright.
Get out.
I'm gonna attack your... I'm gonna autograph your plan.
It's mine now.
Now it's my plan.
Wait.
I have to keep going?
It isn't over?
What do you mean it's not over?
Oh.
I thought it was that easy!
No!
Wait.
I can upgrade.
Okay.
Let's just upgrade our heals.
While we're here.
I mean we might as well upgrade our heals.
I mean... We might... We might as well...
Alright.
Nice.
He's trying to hurt me.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Get out of here.
Alright.
Get out of here, guy.
Please!
There's other women!
There's so many choices!
My plans will carry you and your precious god over the shreds.
Wait.
What?
Okay.
No!
Why did you shot your fucking batterams?
Fuck.
Okay.
That's not good.
She's ready for a run too.
Alright.
Batteram.
God damn it.
I got hit.
Batteram.
I wanna do this.
No!
Oh.
Okay.
I thought I accidentally...
No!
I keep running into it.
God damn it.
I keep accidentally running into obstacles.
Alright.
Out.
Get out.
Batteram.
No.
Not.
Oh.
Okay.
Thank god.
There's friendly fire.
Plants can't see which one's the real Batman.
Concussion.
We're okay.
Doughkeeper confirmed hate environment activist.
Hey!
I was president of my environmental club.
Um.
I don't know how to do this.
I don't know how I became president.
But like...
I was president!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Tom.
What?
Look!
It's... It's still...
It was still... It was still in my college application.
So it counts.
You know, like, I was that type of Asian...
That basically signed up for anything.
For like everything.
So I can like boost up my college application.
Like you might not believe.
Okay.
I...
I want to save the environment.
The environment is very, very important.
But like, you know...
You're not like... Like, you know, THE environmentalist.
Yeah.
I cared about the environment.
But not to the extent where I should have been the president.
It just looked really good on my college applications.
Also...
Andreas, thank you for the five gift of shoes.
Thank you.
I cared enough.
Yes, that's better.
I... I cared enough about the environment.
Okay.
Was it worth it in the end?
I mean, I got to college.
And then I became a VTuber and didn't use my degree for this.
So like...
Yeah.
Hey, hey.
It was Canadian college.
So it's like... You know...
So like the tuition fee was not as bad as American college.
Alright.
Like at least it was... It was Canadian college.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Take his... Kick his ass for Ivy.
Okay.
Please.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Alright.
It's alright.
Just friendly fire.
Alright.
Thank God for friendly fire.
Well... Get out.
Oh God.
I need to get out of here.
Friendly fire.
Okay.
I'll get rid of these guys.
Because apparently it won't stop unless I kill all these... Sorry.
Um... Just make sure they're just... You know, barely alive.
Because Batman doesn't kill.
Alright.
Nice.
Well, we got back up.
Don't worry.
I'm pretty sure Ivy will pay for your family.
Oh.
This way.
I hear you.
So close.
Boop.
Alright.
I think I need two more hits.
Come on.
Open the mouth.
Open the flat mouth.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh.
One hit.
Oh God.
I'm one hit.
She's one hit.
Risk it.
Easy.
Alright.
I'm gonna...
Banksy your plant real quick.
Please be the last one.
That's my signature.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Canadian College Fun.
Bro, this voice acting.
Oh my God.
I'm just like thinking about how...
You know like when you're voice acting, you have to give like a reel of like different like groans and stuff.
Like you're getting hit.
Give me like 30 seconds of that.
I did it, Joker.
Oh, she got another upgrade.
Alright.
Let's upgrade.
We have...
Oh.
No!
Don't...
Okay.
At least it crashed after.
At least it's after.
That's all... That's all that matters.
It crashed after the fight.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna be so sad.
Thank God it wasn't the middle of the Ivy fight.
Oh, thank God.
Alright.
It should have saved.
We just have to listen to Joker talk again.
That's okay.
Alright.
It's alright.
We're almost there.
We're almost at the finale.
We just need... We just have one more boss left apparently.
Alright.
Let's go.
I forgot what I was talking about.
Alright.
Here we go.
The crash.
My biggest boss.
Ta-da!
That's me!
Where did I go?
Okay.
I have to wait until he tells me what to do.
For me?
Whoa!
Sounds so fun, Joker!
Okay.
Alright.
We gotta go to the party.
Oh my God.
I got invited to a party.
Alright.
There's really nothing else to upgrade now.
Right?
His powers.
That was easier.
Wait!
I could have made this easier for myself!
I would have reached and open up access that would otherwise...
Wait!
I could have... I could have made this easier!
Oh, but guys, what if three batter... guys, why didn't you tell me... guys, you know I don't read.
You know I don't fucking read.
I was expecting you guys to help me choose the best upgrades.
But, but Doki, two is... three is better than two.
Guys, we don't need more batterangs.
We don't need more batterangs.
Fine, we'll have more batterangs.
Fine.
Three is better than two.
Alright, where do I go?
Where the fuck's the party?
Three, alright.
Guys, we could have made the hacking easier.
What do you mean?
I would have struggled so hard trying to hack!
Did someone say more batterangs?
I swear to fucking god.
Alright, let's get these guys out of here.
Alright.
Well, it's not really... it can't have more brain damage, right?
They already lost causes, I feel like.
Unless Batman, you know, starts funding the medical...
the medical fund in the city.
I still can't believe Batman was big pharma this entire time.
No wonder everybody's crazy here.
This is how he makes his money.
But the TV is Doki.
Who's that?
What's going on over there?
What is that?
What's that say?
Monster Cell?
Oh my god!
This is it!
Hey guys.
If your name's not on the list, you ain't going in.
But it's me, Batman!
Let's see.
A... no, that's not right.
B... Bane...
Ah!
Here it is.
That's right, I should get VIP right now.
Hey!
I'm the guest of honor?
Give him a big welcome, guys!
It's me, I'm special!
Get some!
Yay!
Oh my god!
Guys, how do you know it's my birthday?
Because every day is my birthday.
Yay!
Happy birthday to me!
What?
Where's the birthdays?
Hello?
Birthday?
Are you excited, Max?
Yeah?
We've been building up to this point all night.
Don't tell me you've not been looking forward to it.
I know I have.
Where's the cake?
Surprise!
Everyone always said I should be in television.
You don't want to miss this.
Really.
It'll be a blast.
Oh my god, you were here this entire time?
Nine.
Eight.
Seven, six, five, four.
Wait, where are you going?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
What?
Oh!
Wait a minute.
Is that a bomb?
Oh, hey, I like how the blast put me closer to the room.
It like sucked me back in.
Why
didn't you stop Batman?
Me?
It was your plan, you goofy clown!
I know.
How did the bomb explode me closer to the window?
It's like a black hole.
I'm sending you back to the ventriloquist where you belong.
Oh shit.
What, is that a guard?
You had to spoil everything, didn't you?
Beating up Bane, feeding Scarecrow to- Whoa!
...what's on your mind, Holly?
My hobby, by the way.
Whoa, Joker!
It's over, Joker.
Over?
Why, my dear?
You're not scared of me, are you?
Joker, damn!
The saddest thing is you know Harley would pay for it too.
That's like the saddest thing.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Alright, it's fine.
We will...
We'll get on top of this guy.
Oh god, oh god, no!
Fuck!
Oh, get away from me, get away from me!
It's alright, there's friendly fo- Please.
Please, game.
Please.
Please, we were so...
Please!
Please let me out!
Let me out!
I just... I just wanna beat the Batman.
I just wanna beat Batman.
Perfectly optimized game.
Guys!
It can't mostly be my PC.
It's also because this game is very old.
And the older games are rarely ever optimized for newer PCs.
Guys!
Look, my PC might be a tomato.
But like...
You can't fully play this.
I'm gonna play it on my PC!
This game needs a remake?
I don't know.
I don't trust remakes anymore.
Unless...
I mean, like, Dead Space is like one of the rare remakes that actually like...
Ow!
Oh, okay.
That didn't hit me.
That's great.
Dead Space is like one of the rare...
rare remakes that like are actually...
they actually...
Oh, nice!
He's better at bowling than me.
Oh, fuck!
Okay!
They already got a remake?
This is the game of the year version.
Wait, when did they get a remake?
Alright, nice.
Got it.
No, no, no, no, no!
Fuck!
They're lying!
Console only.
God damn it!
It's always console only.
Too lazy to play this on console.
Why can't everything be on Steam?
Dude, fuck console exclusives, man.
I hate console exclusives so much.
There's no point!
There's no fucking point!
Bowling!
Console exclusive is fucking stupid.
I'm gonna say it.
Cause eventually...
Nothing is ever console exclusive.
Eventually everything comes back to Steam.
Wow, ouch.
Very hurtful.
Everything eventually gets on Steam.
There's no such thing as console exclusive.
It's all a bait.
It's all a fucking bait!
Except for Nintendo Switch stuff.
Cause like...
It's harder to like port things from the Switch to PC.
Alright, nice.
I'm just gonna use these guys as bowling for a little bit.
Thank God for bowling.
Except Bloodborne...
I feel like eventually Bloodborne will get ported to Steam.
It's just like...
It just takes like...
Uh...
I feel like it...
There has to be like some fucking contract right now that's restricting it from porting it.
But I feel like eventually it's gonna happen.
Okay, nice.
Woo!
Oh!
Get over here!
Nice.
It's time to...
It's time to slap them.
It's time to slap your friends.
That's fucking right.
It's been a decade.
I mean, eventually contracts run out, right?
Right, guys?
I feel like we're gonna see like a remake of Blood...
Uh...
Boop!
Maybe a remaster of Bloodborne.
Or a remaster of Bloodborne on Steam or some shit.
Get the fuck away from me!
Woo!
Leave me alone!
Alright.
Come on, please.
Please kill the rest of the henchmen!
There's like three left!
Just kill the henchmen!
Throw them...
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
No!
How do you miss?
Oh!
You're not me!
How do you miss?
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, slam on the wall.
Ow!
Oh no.
Yes.
Alright.
Good.
I can slap them.
I can slap them now.
Bam.
Alright.
Two...
Wait!
Where did...
How did all these guys keep...
Wait a minute!
Where did all of these guys come from?
Oh shit.
Woo!
No!
My leg!
Where did they come from?
They spawned indefinitely?
No.
The last time you said that, it wasn't true!
There's no way!
The last time you said that, that wasn't true!
No!
I'm not joking this time.
No joking.
This time is for real.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're gonna have to head over to this guy.
Okay, I almost got one down.
That's almost close.
One down.
I'm trying!
There's so many henchmen!
No!
My leg!
Oh!
God damn it, Batman!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh!
I'm like one HP.
I'm like one HP right now.
Please.
Please run over to me.
No!
Don't pick up the body!
All right, I can dodge this.
Whoop!
Oh, well, I guess I'm not gonna be dodging anything.
Oh!
Nice to dodge it!
Thank God!
Woo!
Okay.
I can punch him.
No!
All right, one guy left!
One guy!
No!
Please!
Yes!
Oh!
We got one of them!
Okay, we just gotta leave.
Okay.
This will be easier now.
Now that there's one, it'll be easier.
It should be easier, theoretically.
Theoretically, it should be easier.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
Come on.
Just...
Just run.
Yes!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Oh, thank God!
Oh!
Thank God!
One HP in the dream!
Nice.
Oh!
Shit!
I thought it was over!
I almost could've died.
Nicely done, Bats!
You deserve a prize!
Your old pal, Commissioner Gordon.
Oh!
Gordon?
Say, he looks all run down.
What happened, Gordon?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Batman!
What did he do?
What is this?
Get away!
Oh my God, I'm gonna Bane out.
Here we go!
You're trying to resist a change!
That's not fair!
Oh!
Come on, get in!
Get in!
No!
His pure body!
That's definitely not all natural!
How am I gonna join the Olympics now, Joker?
My big night!
Months of planning down the crapper!
I just wanted to bring down your grim facade and for once, let you see the world as I see it.
Giggling in a corner and bleeding.
But you've denied me even that.
I have nothing to live for.
Oh, shit!
That's actually scary.
Joker on venom juice.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Under lockdown, its staff at the mercy of the rampaging inmates.
Just ten minutes ago, we received this ten-minute report.
first message was a late message.
Greetings, Gotham!
Joker here!
Viva!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, the Olympics are all clean?
Since when?
Whoa!
You should...
That's what you say!
You whispered that!
I like how...
I like how the Bane juice makes him have a mohawk.
As if it affects his fucking hair.
That's for inside voices, not outside voices.
What the fuck?
Two freaks in a fight to the death!
Oh look!
He gets to keep his underwear too.
I feel like the one thing that should have been ripped open is the underwear.
And pants.
No!
Joker, this body is all natural!
I don't need no...
I don't need performance enhancements!
What the fuck is wrong with your nails?
Holy shit!
Joker, cut your nails!
That's so uncomfortable!
Ow!
Alright, how the fuck do I kill you?
Do I throw batarangs at you?
Wait, this is the worst...
Please, we're so close.
Please.
We're so close!
Joker, please!
Oh my god!
How did my crashes get worse?
That's like the one thing I don't understand!
It's like every time I boot up this game, every...
Like, the more days I pass, the worse the crashes get.
Like, how did it get worse?
Oh my god!
Please, we're so close.
We're like literally in the finish line.
We're like literally at the finish line.
Please!
Alright.
Here we go.
It's alright.
It's like I never got slapped in the first place.
Boop!
Ow!
What the fuck?
How do I get away from that?
Alright.
Bob Joker is too strong.
What do I do?
Alright.
I mean, these guys are easy to beat.
As long as they're not the tanky ones, that's fine.
I'm fine if they're not the super tanky ones.
Wait, there's presents!
For me?
Okay.
Throw.
Nice.
It's fine.
I can literally just X everything.
X, X, X.
X and then Y.
Gosh.
No!
It's never good to counter!
There's never a good time to counter!
Oh shit.
How do I get rid of this?
How do I get rid of teeth?
Teeth!
Get away from me, teeth!
Alright, nice.
I just need to help the other one.
Use the middle stick to avoid the crashes.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Now I can just Y everything.
Nope.
Never mind.
What?
What's going on?
What the fuck happened?
Wow!
Oh my god!
What the fuck happened?
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Batman's fucking up my PC!
Batman's like fucking up my PC!
My PC's like, please!
Please beat Batman!
Please!
Holy shit!
Please beat Batman!
We need you to beat Batman!
Oh my god!
Bro, my fucking thing is freaking out right now!
Everything is freaking out!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
I don't know.
I don't know if it's okay.
Please get me out of this hellhole!
Get me out!
Ow!
Holy shit!
Please!
Let me kill Batman!
Not Batman!
Let me kill Joker!
Oh my god!
Wait, there's more?
Oh god!
Am I back in it?
Use your imagination!
Bro, we're not back!
Holy shit!
Where am I?
Oh my god!
Give me a sec!
It's a journey right now!
It's a journey!
Hahaha!
Holy shit!
It's okay, we're here!
It's okay!
We're almost back, guys!
I just need you guys to know my OBS window is also frozen.
So I don't even know what it looks like right now.
I don't even know!
My OBS window is actually frozen.
So like, I don't even know what it looks like at the moment.
I...
Okay, I'm just gonna assume I'm back up.
I'm gonna assume...
Am I...
Am I on the screen?
Guys, am I on the s- Oh!
That's not...
Okay, that's not what I wanted.
Extra life.
Okay.
Alright, this one.
This is the right one, I think.
Yeah, there we go!
I had to look at my YouTube preview.
We're fine!
Everything's fine!
Alright, here we go!
We're back!
How do I kill Joker?
Please.
Oh, God.
Please, we need to get me out of here!
Get me outta here!
Ow!
I wasn't looking!
It's okay, we're fine.
We're back.
Use the Bat Claw!
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
I have to use the Bat Claw.
For my pure intuition, I figured out how to kill Joker.
Aw, that's mean.
What?
Ow.
I'm done here!
Nice, I got him!
I did it all by myself!
Get down!
My natural intuition!
Without looking at chat!
Boom, boom!
That's fucking right, you're never gonna get out of this.
Ow!
Okay, can I run away from this?
What if I just... Alright, round two.
Oh my god, it's like Mario!
Three hits and you're out!
Okay, what if I... I have three batarangs right now.
Alright, nice.
Oh shit!
Nice.
We're fine, we're fine.
Everything is fine.
I'm doing all the combos necessary.
Okay.
Look at that, I'm comboing!
Finally!
It took me the rest of this game to learn how to combo!
Oh god, maybe my... Yes, okay, I just need to bait these guys.
To kill them.
Oh shit, nope.
No knife.
It's alright, we're good.
Just have to keep...
We just have to make sure we don't get hit.
Everything will be fine.
Alright, nice.
Explode.
Hold down!
Just don't hit me!
No!
I'm so close!
Why didn't you come down?
No!
It's not fair!
It should be like a magical girl cutscene where nothing interrupts you when I transform into a magical girl, but instead nobody interrupts me when I fucking try to kill Joker.
There's no etiquette!
I can't believe it!
Alright.
It's okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Where is the etiquette?
You're supposed to not touch somebody when they're doing this.
I'm not doing the cutscene.
I'll give you something for the morning news Gotham!
No, it's like when you're in a cutscene, you don't interrupt them!
That's always the rule!
I'm gonna explode.
Please!
No!
So close!
You brought me back.
Stop!
I'm gonna go away!
Please!
Stop!
This is not fair.
This is not fair!
This boss fight fucking sucks!
I can't believe it.
Why does it take so long?
Batman!
Why don't you have better upper body strength?
I don't understand.
Why?
Why are you not jacked enough?
Okay, here we go.
Jack Ryder!
Can you hear me?
Okay.
Alright, here we go!
We got it!
Hey!
Here we go!
Batman!
You could have made more antidotes!
You'll die!
Alright, nice.
Alright, one more.
We just need one more.
And then we should be fine.
You ready for this?
Can I just run away?
There's no way.
I understand now.
Never dodge, bro.
Just run.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Last one.
There's no way I can get distracted this time.
As long as I keep...
As long as I keep throwing my punch.
Ow.
Oh no.
Oh no, he has guns.
No!
Why are you letting them have guns now?
This is not fair!
Okay.
I gotta get rid of him.
Oh god, oh god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get the gun away.
No guns!
No guns allowed!
Melees only!
Okay.
I gotta get rid of him.
Bye.
I don't like...
I don't like the fucking...
Okay, I'm gonna hope the bombs will kill them for me.
Okay.
God damn it.
There's so many.
Oh!
Who has the gun?
How did you get the gun?
Oh shit.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
How did you get a gun?
Where did you get that?
Alright.
I gotta make sure...
Trigger.
Nice.
Okay.
Why?
Dodge?
God.
No wonder.
Everyone was like, this is the worst one.
No wonder everyone was like, this is the worst boss fight.
I...
I agree.
I fucking agree.
This is the worst boss fight.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Got that.
Then...
Get closer.
No, it's not close enough!
Please, jump!
Okay, thank god.
No, no, no, not the gun!
Okay, we got rid of the gun.
Yes!
No!
Please don't get closer!
No, no, no, no, no!
Fuck you!
Nooooo!
My buddy died!
How did you live?
Who let you live?
Okay, there we go.
We should be fine.
Please, please, do not get close to me!
Please!
Oh my god.
How do they keep coming back?
It's just, it's always the one guy.
Why is it always the one guy?
No, no.
Okay, fine.
It's always the one guy.
Okay.
There's no way I can get interrupted now.
No!
It's always you!
Terrible new one for me!
I always keep getting one guy.
Like, how is this possible?
How is this possible?
How is it always one?
I don't understand.
Okay, there's no way.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
One shot!
Okay.
We gotta get rid of all three.
I don't trust all of these guys.
Okay!
There's no way!
There is no way!
How?
Oh my god.
I don't know how this keeps happening to me.
I...
This is actually, like, impressive.
I... I can't even...
You know what?
This is actually pretty impressive now.
It's...
Oh, this is...
Oh, god.
I'm sorry, Gordon!
I keep getting one guy!
I'm so sorry!
I...
I'm sorry, Gordon!
I don't know how this keeps happening!
I've got a message for all my adoring fans in...
There's no way!
No!
Tonight, Gotham, I have defeated your dear Dark Knight.
I have defeated your dear Dark Knight.
He's still alive!
Let's get ready to...
There's no way!
Why is it always one guy?
How is this possible?
How is it always one person that was alive?
How?
I thought they were all dead!
There's no fucking way!
I'm actually so unlucky.
I've never been so unlucky before.
Oh my god.
To think...
Everyone's dead except for one.
Except for one!
That's actually so unlucky.
Get out!
Alright.
Explode.
Build Water.
So  I can't believe it.
I would think that they're dead, but then they keep coming back.
They keep coming back!
It never stops.
Are you all down?
Are you all down for once?
Oh my god.
How have I got such a dumb bird brain as my Oshii?
How was I supposed to know that one guy?
This has nothing to do with luck.
I thought he was dead!
Alright, here we go.
We're fine this time.
It's fine this time.
I'll double tap for real, guys.
Don't worry.
I'll double tap this time.
I swear.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll double tap.
I've learned my lesson.
Chat, I've learned my lesson.
Alright.
Now I know what to do.
Nice.
Okay.
Got it.
I got it.
What?
I totally dodged it!
I 100% dodged that.
I swear.
Okay.
Alright.
They're all dead.
I won't get one guy this time.
See?
I'm learning!
I've learned!
I told you guys.
I told you guys I can learn!
Why did he let Matt hit him?
Is he stupid?
I'm double tapping!
There you go.
Easy.
See?
I told you I can learn!
I told you guys!
Alright.
Let me get rid of these guys.
Dodge.
Counter.
Alright.
Throw.
Can I throw them actually?
Oh my god!
Look!
I have a critical hit!
I'm comboing!
14!
Ow!
Oh shit!
Nice.
Alright.
We're fine.
Okay.
We gotta get...
Oh shit!
Not the guns!
Not the gun!
Okay.
We gotta get rid of him.
And then punch him in the back.
Okay.
I'm gonna get rid of him.
Oh!
Go!
Oh my god!
There's still so many!
No!
He's going for the gun!
There's no gun for you!
Okay.
As long as there's...
As long as he doesn't get the gun, we're fine.
I just hope he... I just want him to not hold the gun.
Alright.
How many more are there?
Woo!
Okay.
Last guy.
Alright.
Nice!
I told you I can learn!
I double attacked for real.
I did it!
Maybe he just...
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
That's like a broken hand right there.
Like he literally put explosives on his hand.
Like what the fuck!
Holy fuck!
Yeah.
Sorry, Barbara.
I sort of...
He got electrocuted several times.
Because I kept getting one guy.
And the Venom enhanced inmates are returning to normal.
But what about the bones?
The process can be quite painful.
I'll survive.
See you tonight, Barbara.
Shame about your car.
This is a big damage, Barbara.
Thanks, Jim.
But I have one on the way.
Get some rest.
You deserve it.
Stay safe, Jim.
Two officers down.
The suspect is fleeing in their patrol car.
Yeah.
His arm...
His hatchet.
That is definitely broken.
Holy fuck!
We did it!
We beat Batman!
Wait!
I could have beat this game...
I could have beat this game two days ago!
In part three!
You guys were like...
Oh, it's gonna take her like...
Two to three more hours.
I could have literally played...
An hour and we could have just...
Beat the game.
Two days ago.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it.
What do you mean it almost took me two hours?
It took me an hour!
We had like 20 minutes of...
In the beginning.
I can't believe...
You guys baited me into...
Doing a part four.
Holy shit!
This game fucking...
Oh my god!
My PC was fucking crying while playing this game.
Anyway!
Now that I finished...
Batman!
The next long game...
The next series...
Play through I'm gonna do...
Is Resident Evil 4.
Finally!
I cannot wait to do the escort missions again.
The rest of the game...
Remastered.
We're gonna do Resident Evil 4.
For next week.
Our new play through.
I wrote down a shitload of games.
Is that the same fucking picture?
Of Batman beating up a guy again?
I swear I just saw this.
Also Taurus!
Thank you for the five!
I was writing a bunch of games.
And stuff that I wanna do.
That I wanna play.
Now that I can play as an indie.
Oh my god.
Okay wait.
Let me...
Okay we don't care about the credits anyway.
Hahahaha!
Let me look at it.
Alright I actually made a little games list too.
Okay there's like...
Let's see.
I have Freddy Fish.
God of War.
Shadow of Colossus.
Monster Ranch.
Club Penguin.
Umm...
Digimon World.
The Batman Telltale series.
Oh my god.
I'm planning on trying to...
Buy the Minecraft...
Telltale series.
On like...
Do they have the Minecraft Telltale series on the Xbox?
Do they have it on the Playstation?
Or is it an Xbox exclusive?
Cause then I need to buy an Xbox.
I need to buy an Xbox.
Hahahaha!
Is the...
Is the Minecraft Telltale series...
Only on Xbox?
Cause like you can't get it online anymore.
You have to... Yeah the story mode.
Minecraft story mode.
Because like I need to buy an Xbox then.
Oh it has a Playstation?
Okay.
I'm gonna try and buy a hard copy.
Of the Minecraft story mode.
Because it's so... I've never like...
I've never like played it before.
But I've seen like videos of the...
Of the pig dying.
Okay have you guys... It's on Netflix?
Well you can watch that.
But you can play the Minecraft Telltale series.
On the Playstation.
It's unav... You can't...
You can't like buy it.
You can't buy a digital copy of it anymore.
You have to like buy the hard copy.
Because it's like...
Hahaha!
It's like... It's like what's the word?
They like took it out cause they wanna pretend...
It doesn't exist.
Hahaha!
They... They wanna pretend...
They never made a Minecraft story game.
Hahaha!
So... If it's on the...
Okay so...
For those who don't know.
There's like an infamous scene where...
The pig dying...
Wait let me say I could find it.
It's so fucking funny.
It's actually...
Watch the credits...
Let's skip the credits.
Is there an after credits scene?
Oh there is an after credits scene!
It's so good.
I wanna like live through that.
Watch this.
Oh my god, Scarecrow, he's alive?
Who would have thought?
It's as if he never died.
Alright, I need to show you guys.
I need to show you guys.
Let me get rid of this.
All unsaved.
Yes, I already finished the game.
Okay, Minecraft...
Pig...
Story mode.
It's so good.
Look at...
Wait, is this one?
Okay, wait.
Minecraft story mode.
Reuben's death.
Alright, here it...
Sorry.
It's so fucking funny.
Okay.
Okay, this is the...
This is what I'm talking about.
I wanted to play the Minecraft story mode because of...
Because of this scene where the pig fucking dies.
Because it's supposed to be like super fucking sad.
And then he dies.
And then he turns into fucking pork.
Reuben!
I don't know who you are!
Doki, please.
Spoilers.
This is the only thing I'll spoil.
Because it's so fucking funny.
It turns into fucking pork.
Like, what the fuck?
Holy shit.
I remember thinking that was sad.
Like, it's just a floating pork.
Anyway.
I wanna...
Reuben will be remembered.
Oh my god, he just picks up the pork chop!
What the f...
He's just picking up the pork chop!
Anyway, I really wanna play Minecraft story mode.
Um, a little bit of...
Okay, so yeah, like I said, I wrote down all these games I wanna play.
So, another one was Disney Dreamlight Valley.
Which was the...
Which is basically the Animal Crossing of Disney.
Microsoft Flight Simulator.
Train Simulator.
DuckTales Remastered.
Dead Rising!
Okay, I've always wanted to try out Dead Rising.
I think Dead Rising would be really fun.
Crash Bandicoot Trilogy and Racing.
Tokyo Jungle.
Sleeping Dogs.
The original Kingdom Hearts.
Halo Infinite.
Or like anything from Halo.
Sunset Overdrive.
And then I was watching Surefour play like Supermarket Simulator.
And then I was like, You know what?
I wanna know what it's like to be a...
To make minimum wage.
I was watching Surefour play Supermarket Simulator for like...
Like I wasn't watching for 7 hours.
I watched like the last 2 hours of it.
And it's like that type of game where like you just turn off your brain and just like...
Turn off your brain and restock.
Um...
Anyway.
Kyle!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
PlayStation like Metal Gear.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dark Hunter.
Hey Doki.
Meant to become a member on my birthday this past Saturday.
But better late than never.
Eh?
Love you and all the things you do.
Great stream so far.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you guys have been enjoying it.
But yeah, there's like... I've been like slowly writing down all the games that I wanted to play.
That I've been wanting to play like the past couple of years.
So like I'm like super excited to like try like eventually do everything on this list.
There's like... Oh my god!
I love how like people were like when they saw the Sonic game that I put for this week.
People were like Oh my god!
She's fun!
She's gonna be playing Sonic!
And then they read which type of Sonic I'm gonna be playing.
And everyone was like... Oh...
It's that Sonic game!
That's so funny.
People were like...
Oh no!
The monkey paw is like... Doki's gonna play Sonic!
It's Sonic Dreams Collection.
Pikachu!
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
Um...
All you Zoomers and and uh...
Gen A, you guys were not... You guys never lived until you saw Sonic Dreams Collection.
Which is in my opinion, one of the best Sonic games out there.
I've never played Sonic Dreams Collection before.
I remember when it first came out and I seen like like a play through of it.
Um... And honestly, in my opinion, definitely one of the best Sonic games out there.
Did you guys know that the creators of Sonic Dreams Collection went on to create Neon White?
I think...
I think that's...
That's actually crazy.
That the creator of Sonic Dreams Collection made Neon White.
Like the jump between that to... This was the origin story.
The origin story of the devs of Neon White.
That's so... That's insane.
Um... And also Tattletale?
Like the Indie Horror Game?
Uh... Indie Mascot Horror Game.
Um...
Let's see.
DDragon, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did somebody say Crash Team Racing?
I remember I talked about it before.
But I think Crash Team Racing is one of the best... Uh...
One of the best racing games out there.
I like that more than Mario Kart.
I enjoy Crash...
Crash Bandicoot Racing more than Mario Kart.
Uh... Yeah, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kaito!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for being a amazing streamer, Doki.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
We finished our first game!
We finished our first series!
I'm so happy.
Uh...
Our first series that we finished was Batman.
Um...
Aipen!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, it was my birthday yesterday.
Thank you for being there and making me laugh for another year while I get old.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
Happy birthday.
Happy belated birthday to you.
Happy belated birthday dear Aipen!
Yeah!
Also Liam, thank you for the magenta superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's one of the best Sonic games in my opinion.
I never played it.
Never changed.
Doki.
Thank you for the magenta superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's no problem guys.
I still think it's one of the best Sonic games out there.
That's why you know it's good.
I've never played it but I think it's the best one.
That's when you know it's a really good Sonic game.
You don't have to play it to know it's like peak Sonic.
Um...
Nexy, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Super excited for you and all the fun games you have planned.
Congrats on finishing your first series.
Thank you!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you guys.
Yeah.
This was a very short stream.
Um...
I legitimately thought it would be a lot longer.
I mean to be fair, uh... to be fair like I did I feel like I was going... my PC was going through a lot like the last like uh two days ago.
It was going through a lot.
I was on fucking wifi and like my crashes was insane.
But like yeah we made it through.
We powered through guys.
We powered through.
Guys, I swear it's not a PC.
Okay, maybe it's a little bit of a PC issue.
Okay?
But like I swear guys it's not just my PC though.
It can't just be my PC.
There were more there was more at stake with the game.
Um... but yeah!
Anyway, I actually have a lot of behind the scenes work to do today.
So I'm gonna call it here.
I really want to do as long as that's done.
But I have like a huge list of stuff to do for work today.
Um... because like it's never over.
Work is never over.
There's so many adult things to do.
Oh my god.
Me and Mr. Man were talking about like payroll and stuff.
And like we were like negotiating pays and salaries and stuff.
And I was just like Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I had to open ANOTHER BITCH!
I was like there's so much work to do.
I just wanna stream Batman and be a silly anime girl.
That's all I wanna do.
But I have to... I have to do so much adult things.
Anyway, Araborninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
DokiBirdsufferingfromsuccess, thank you for the super chat.
Work is never over.
Anyway, I'm going to call it here guys.
Thank you everybody for coming.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Any of you except for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!